well welcome everybody this is what I'm
not nervous and speaking in front of a
large crowd but about to welcome you
here tonight and I will think of quality
rather than quantity and before cape
comes up and consists talk on introduce
you to Roger
Kimball the editor of new criteria and a
fellow author and friend and he was good
he's going to tell you about Keith
thanks very much among the very good
advice that Samuel Johnson gave to
people he once gave this advice to
parents said accustom yourselves always
accustom yourselves if a thing happened
at one window and your children when
relating it say that it happened at
another window do not let it pass but
check it instantly because you never
know where deviation from truth will
stop well one place that it stops is in
the utter corruption of the very idea of
truths of factual truths in the Academy
we have today in many I've ventured to
say in most universities a kind of taken
for granted attitude that there is no
really such thing as a fact there are
matters of opinion this is a corrosive
inheritance
from a number of intellectual sources
all of which Keith winshuttle details
brilliantly in his book the killing of
history now I hope all of you have heard
of this book and that many of you have
bought it those of you who have not
bought it you now have the opportunity
to do so in the economically priced
paperback you also can read mr.
winshuttle in the current issue of the
new criterion where he writes about the
British Empire and this abuses the
innocent reader of the prevalent but
poisonous idea that somehow British
imperialism was a wicked thing apart
from the Academy this moral perversity
and intellectual dishonesty that we see
with the rejection of the idea of
factual truth it also has had a very
corrosive influence on our public life
on our media
even on certain political figures who
when charged with gross misbehavior
think that they can cheat the charge of
perjury by saying that it all depends on
what the meaning of the word is is I
mentioned this last fact because we
shouldn't think that the kinds of
intellectual dishonesty that mr.
winshuttle chronicles brilliantly in the
killing of history are only a matter of
Airy academic speculation they affect
public discourse in the most intimate
possible way and it is mr. Wynn
shuttle's great accomplishment in this
book to have laid out in a series of
telling and vivid anecdotes the entire
history of how this attack on factual
truth and the undermining of historical
truth has come about Keith winshuttle
thank thanks Roger I should say that
this paperback edition in indeed none of
the American editions of the killing of
history would exist if it wasn't for
Roger because he was the one who picked
up the book so he tells me from a pile
of used books that were destined to go
to a secondhand bookstore and flicking
through the pages thought oh this sounds
interesting and eventually end up
writing a review for The Wall Street
Journal which sort of made the sales go
through the roof or almost immediately
and which led to an American publisher
taking up the book Free Press in the in
hardback and now the book has been taken
up by encounter books in in a paperback
edition which is what I'm here to
introduce tonight so I owe a great debt
to Roger into the new criterion for
giving a little Ozzie Butler that kind
of first-rate often running start in in
the United States very competitive book
market I'd also like to thank the
Australian consul for this venue tonight
which is is just perfect for what we've
what we want to do here now I was in San
Francisco the week before I came here
and did it doing a series of radio
interviews with talkback hosts and one
of them started off by reading to me
from the introduction my little brief
statement of the various theories that
I'm criticizing and he read so I say
you're talking about cultural relativism
semiotics structuralist theory post
structuralist theory anti humanism
discourse theory
hey Galen and Marxist philosophy post
modernist philosophy radical skepticism
hermeneutics the theory of poetics he
said now what the hell does that all
mean and as you might imagine there was
a couple of seconds of absolute dead
silence on his radio program because how
do you respond to to that kind of
question when you think should I start
saying well now structuralist theory and
running through the various points
they're all post structuralist theory
should I respond to that
fortunately the idea came to me that
that the whole range
the fact that there are so many theories
that you can list that a book like mine
is criticizing is indicative of how much
fashionable discourse or how much
fashionable Theory there is in this
whole business which is sometimes called
post-modernism sometimes called post
structuralism which is today it goes
under the and under the general rubric
of of cultural studies but the fact that
there is such a range of different
titles means that that that there isn't
it there's no stability in the in the
various theories that that Mobile's
criticizing it indicates that the
radical critique of Western society and
Western ways of knowing which is what my
book is intended to counter as followed
a shifting pattern of fashionable
changes over the last twenty years the
most devastating critique that a post
modernist can make of anybody is to say
that his work or his theory is out of
date now in contrast history is an
intellectual discipline that goes back
two and a half thousand years the first
true historian in my view is acidities
who wrote in 400 BC in in in Athens and
the basic methodology that Thucydides
laid down then is still alive today the
techniques of history were refined in
the early 19th century in largely in
Germany by rancor and and and his
disciples and put on a properly academic
footing but but for the past 200 years
the methods of verification
corroboration of documentary proof of of
the event you're talking about has been
pretty much static so in in the mark of
that I mean as a critic of what in in my
view are the dominant theories of of how
we understand history and how we
approach the humanities in general to
take a critical stance against that by
arguing from tradition and especially
arguing from history which which really
has a very
people methodology and if the acidity
said the the basis of his methodology
was to he said I've never written in
this book
history the Peloponnesian War about
anything that I have other not witnessed
myself or not have heard from other
people of whom I made the most careful
investigation now that methodology
obviously is very simple compared to the
theories of language and and the
ontology and epistemology that your
average University student gets if he
does the humanities degree and he
majored in history today
and so to defend something traditional
and relatively uncomplicated is really
to put yourself behind the behind the
eight-ball to start with because it's
very difficult to to argue that you've
got an interesting point but but it
seems to me that the defense of the
traditional methods of history and
especially of its pursuit of truth and
objectivity really goes to the core of
what Western society is all about and
and it's not just simply a method of one
particular intellectual discipline
although it is that it's also an idea
that distinguishes which Western culture
from every other culture that human
beings have ever devised the idea that
you can pursue the truth in an objective
sense that is free from the influence of
the prevailing political system or free
from the influence of the prevailing
religious system is a Western idea
lucidity invented it and and it means
that what what you can do is to sort of
look down from an outside position on
your own society and be a critic of your
own society and that happens to be in my
view one of the keys to the success of
the whole Western cultural endeavor
those who inherit the yard
those of us who've inherited the culture
that that we can be self-critical we are
free to criticize our political system
we are free to criticize our religious
and cultural values in any way we choose
have I mean there been people who've
been prepared to died to defend those
those principles and so to see the
university system virtually throw them
away on the basis of fashion and on the
pursuit of ever-changing theories is
very disappointing and what I try to do
in the killing of history is not only to
point out just what's going on but also
to to criticize the variate the
varieties of theory and the different
epistemological and ontological
approaches that are involved in the
alternative views that are in order to
show that in themselves they have no
value but also if we accept them then we
accept that then we reject one of the
basic premises of of Western cultural
life now when that that radio
interviewer asked me what the hell is
this all about
apart from fashion change another thing
it's about is is the politicization of
an important stream of academic life the
the the theories that I'm criticizing
and are only part of a non only directed
at history they've been alive much
longer in English literary criticism and
and they permeate the humanities
generally in in one way there are they
are a continuation of the critique of
Western society by other means in after
1989 it no longer became viable to
criticize Western society from a Marxist
point of view even though there are
still people who adhere to Marxist
critiques of Western society today it
became much more sophisticated to
criticize it from a post structuralist
post modernist point of view because
then you're no longer tying yourself to
what the post modernists call the old
meta meta narratives of of Marxism or of
anything that might smack of support for
the now-defunct Soviet Union and but
what we've seen in the politicization of
of the humanities is instead of the
revolutionary proletariat which was the
vanguard of history for Marxist theory
we've seen a whole range of groups who
the subjects of of this are these
particular theoretical endeavors in
particular political political identity
groups post-modernism post-structuralist
and cultural studies in in a very
profound sense are the ideologies of the
political interest groups especially a
feminism of ethnocentrism and of various
romantic movements about indigenous
peoples that that have become prominent
in in the last 20 years and and the
critique of of Western society has gone
hand in hand with the critique of
Western ways of knowing of Western
epistemology and and what the arguments
been is that people who who are
non-western who are non-white who are
from ethnic groups that that are outside
the realm of Western culture have
non-western ways of knowing and that the
idea that Western ways of knowing that
that that that Western history might be
a universal way of understanding the
movement of society is simply hubris
it's simply a myth that has been
concocted by previous historians in the
days when history was a discipline that
was only confined and only written by
people in the West and if the new
identity groups and they can be identity
groups within Western society or in
particular they can be identity groups
Muslims or Indians
I mean Indians from India who are one of
the important groups leading leading at
this particular theoretical movement
they have their own ways of knowing and
they want to develop their own
techniques of studying society and
understanding how human society works
what I try to argue in this in this book
is that even for those groups to throw
away the method of of Western history
would be to throw away the best tools
that that people from non-western
countries especially people from poor
countries
understand their own predicament and
have working why working to get out of
their own predicament with the I
mentioned the Indian historians there's
a group called the subaltern group of
historians who argue that on the Indians
can write Indian history and this is a
corollary with feminist groups who argue
that only women can write women's
history the problem with that argument
is that if you flip it over onto the
reverse side its arguing that women
cannot write men's history or the
history about about miles and and
non-indians have no right to to write
Indian history and some of the best
history of India has been written by
non-indian historians it's also ironic
that the the theories that the subaltern
group use in order to reject Western
ways of historical inquiry derive in
fact from a different Western tradition
but a Western one no less which is a
tradition derived from the Italian
Marxism of Antonio Gramsci
so they're applying a Western form of
theory in order to reject Western ways
of knowing which is to say the least
self contradictory and and an obvious
recipe for for confusion
I might give an IDE an idea of the
structure of the book what I didn't want
to do in in preparing a reply to a range
of wildering theory was to write a
theoretical book and I tried to look for
examples where the theorists or the
theories that I'm criticizing approach
to historical topic and I wanted to
treat that as a to look at case studies
to look at the historical topics of the
veil addressed and then to compare that
with the way that traditional historians
had addressed the same topic and I
arranged through a whole range of
historical topics in the book from the
conquest of Mexico or in fact the
earliest example I use is late medieval
Europe but the conquest of Mexico gets a
lengthy treatment the Battle of Quebec
in 1759 the mutiny on the bounty the
foundation of Australia the the fall of
communism in 1989 are all historical
topics that I look at the theorists on
criticizing how they have treated the
subject matter and then look at how a
regular historian a traditional
historian using the traditional
methodology of the discipline approaches
the same subject matter to see who wins
and from what I said so far it's
obviously no surprise that in every case
the good guys win the traditional
historians come out on top and the
theorists are left with with an
embarrassing position let me give you a
couple of examples one is is is Greg
Jennings book on the mutiny on the
bounty mr. Bligh's bad language
now the reason Denning chose to write a
book on the minion about him from a
structuralist theoretical position is
because it's been it's been discussed so
often and so many times there are more
than a thousand books on the mutiny on
the bounty since in in the little more
than 200 years since the event occurred
there are five movies three in how I
wouldn't to
a homegrown Australian movies on the
subject and dennings point in sort of
running through the range of approaches
to the meeting about he is is they all
change that there's no one particular
view of the mutiny on the bounty that in
early on in the nineteenth century
Bligh is the good guy in Fletcher
Christian is a terrible reprobate who
deserved the early death that he that he
earned as for his his deeds in the 20th
century Bligh becomes the bad guy
Fletcher Christian is the young hero
who's who suffered subjected to an
intolerable intolerable abuse by Bligh
and understandably responds as as an III
freedom-loving man would and then he
says that their shades of difference all
the way through over the last two
hundred years and the various other
approaches to the subject he said what
this tells us is that is that in each
era or at each span of years what people
see in the mutiny on the bounty is what
their own culture wants to see in the
mutiny on the bounty the differing
interpretations don't reflect any
changes in the mutiny on the bounty
itself they reflect the cultural changes
of the people who are looking back at
that event and the argues from that
position to a more general point is that
whenever we look at history all we see
is our own culture reflected back at us
we can never go back and see the event
as it really happened the the admonition
by Leopold von ranked the great German
historian who who really defined the
discipline of history in the early 9th
century to tell history as it really was
is impossible says Craig Denning because
we are all cocooned in their own culture
we can't break free of that we are
locked in into our own cultural visors
and and history is really about the
presence the study history is really
under study historians it's really to
tell us more about ourselves rather than
about the events in the past we're
looking at and so we get
a an interpretation of the shifting
views of the mutiny on the bounty from
Denning to sort of trying to stablish
that case now as part of his argument he
argues that there was a view in nearly
twentieth century in fact up until the
time he was writing in the early
nineties that bla was a situs that the
that Fletcher Christian was perfectly
justified in rebelling because I used to
flog the men and abused them in a
terrible way that was unconscionable and
that any true man would rebel against
and would terrible other deities would
mutiny against and then dead he says but
but this is not so this is another myth
this is this is an illusion but by
previous cultural perspectives and he
gives us some data about floggings of
all the about all the ships that that
explored from the Pacific in the 18th
century and he shows that that because
the records of floggings have to be kept
by the captain and there's and that's
they were all documented and it turns
out that Vancouver was the was the worst
example was the worst perpetrator of
floggings on his men in the in the 18th
century cook followed by cook and Bly of
all the sea captains who English sea
captains who explored the Pacific in
that period was the least inclined to
use the lash on his crew now Denning
then uses that point that previous views
that blower the side is a myth as part
of this general argument that that we
can't know history as it really was yet
of course his evidence about Bligh using
the lash it's a piece of evidence about
history as it really was he relies upon
an example from history that actually
happened to argue that we can't know
that his history
eventually happened and and as she run
through the book you'll find that this
is a position that repeats itself you
know almost every example whether the
theorist be post-structuralist
structuralist cultural studies or
whatever to deny the veracity the
objectivity of the truthfulness of
history they
have to rely upon the fact that
somewhere in the historical record there
is truth there's a platform of truth
sustained in order to argue their
position another historian who does the
same thing is Simon Schama one of the
one of the best-selling historians of
the last 20 years he published a book
called did certainties in the early
1990s which did which had two things
which I object to one was he invented
part of the story there's what purports
to be an eyewitness account of the early
early stages of the Battle of Quebec in
1759 from one of the common soldiers and
the language is the language of the
common soldier and even the spelling has
alien century conventions built into it
and any reader who comes to the first
time obviously believes this is a
verbatim report that that that genre is
discovered it's only when you reach the
end of the book and start reading the
end notes that you find that this is a
composite constructed piece now what the
main objection to that as any reader who
who's been sort of seduced into the book
would immediately tell you is that it's
dishonest it's it's a con you think that
you're getting reality and then you find
all you're getting is a secondary
interpretation by historian dressed up
as the real thing that's bad enough but
the real point that we're Sharma is is
at fault in my view is that he argues
like denning that we can't know that the
past that history is an illusion history
is construction that that that we are
cocooned in our cultures and can't break
free of it
and he gives the example of the famous
painting by benjamin west of the death
of general wolf at in the Battle of
Quebec and he argues that the painting
it's it's most people who see it believe
it it's a a battlefield scene sort of
social realist with Benjamin West whole
Dee's breasts lying stretched out these
officers looking concerned around him
but knowing that this is the he's about
to take his last breath and Seamus is
now rather than being a genuine
portrait of the battlefield this in fact
is is an historical illusion and then it
gives a very convincing case of how the
lighting of the painting and the staging
of the characters in the painting
resembled the conventions of the 18th
century London stage that the alien
century London stage put people in these
positions they stood them in certain
positions to get a three-dimensional
effect that the lighting the candle
lighting that you get on the stage is
the same lighting as the battlefield in
Quebec reproduces it's not the authentic
battlefield lighting
it's a staged lighting effect and so he
says that all historical evidence is of
this kind it's all constructed and it's
all distorted and and basically it's an
illusion but they're to establish that
point we have to believe that what
denning that what shana tells us about
the conventions of the London stage is
in fact accurate because if his account
of the conventions of the lighting and
the positioning of the characters on the
London stage is itself an illusion which
in his own theory that's all we have an
illusion of an illusion then why should
we rely upon it why should we take his
word that the the battlefield portrait
of by Benjamin West is an illusion if
the only evidence for it is itself
illusionary and in every case the
attempt to deny truth and objectivity as
I try and show in the book falls under
the same kind of of logic I mean the
worst example is great Denning where he
criticizes the Hollywood movies on the
mutiny on the bounty in the 1930s the
Charles Laughton movie Charles Laughton
and as Captain Bligh and Clark Gable
with Fletcher Christian it had Bligh
returned to England after he was after
he lost his ship and then refitting
another ship returning to the Pacific in
order to capture the mutineers now as
anyone who's read the history of the
these events knows the real person who
who came back to the Pacific to pursue
the mute news was Captain Edward
woods and the ply stayed at home and and
Denning is is very critical of this he
says look isn't Hollywood I mean it's
very fashionable in Australia to to sort
of decry Hollywood as being all of
American culture and and he's really
saying look at the Americans hopeless at
history because you know it was they
been able to pursued such a Christian
not not Captain Bligh but of course
somebody with dennings view of history
that is that we don't discover history
we invent history we create it he says
quite openly history is fictions not a
form of fact that anyone with that view
can't make those kind of criticisms you
can't complain if a different character
is put into the historical record
because after all the whole thing is an
invention and so why can't Hollywood
invent its own its own version now these
are logical points but if you think
about it it's not difficult to show that
there are political points that the that
that the advocates of these theories
also have to address which are no less
edifying now as I said before most of
the most of the people who who support
the theories that I'm criticizing do so
on behalf of speaking on behalf of
various political interest groups and
the main ones are feminists ethnic
groups and and various other groups who
are critical of Western society and and
the argument is we can interpret history
any way we like in fact let me let me
quote you in order to convince you just
how how sort of stark the argument is
this is from the introduction to a book
called the post modern history reader by
Keith Jenkins and it's it's a book which
is now a mainstream textbook in widely
used in courses in historical method in
the american university system and
jenkins says such demystification can
free up historians to tell many equally
legitimate stories from various
viewpoints with umpteen voices in
comments and types of synthesis it is in
this sense that we can interpret the
past any way we like and it is in this
conclusion which signals too many normal
historians the end of their kind of
history well now one of the problems
that view is if you simply use
postmodern theory to justify feminist
interpretations of history that all men
oppress women and the rest of the that
argument then the people advocating this
series that might be satisfied with that
but that argument also justifies its
sanctions the or it sanctions other
views that that the Keith Jenkins of the
world might not not find so congenial
because those who deny the Holocaust
occurred can use exactly the same
argument white supremacists can say we
have our legitimate views too and we
want to write history any way we like
and if you accept that then there is no
you have no political grounds in which
to object to them you can't appeal to
truth you can appeal to objectivity you
can't say well effects contradict your
your views your left
I mean you throw away history and that's
why my book is called the killing of
history and when history is not dead yet
because obviously if I'm using the
examples of traditional historians to
argue against these theorists then
there's still a body of work being
written that that that is on the side of
traditional values but but the the
people who the post modernist version of
history history that fails to confront
the fact that there are political views
which it will not like but which it
legitimizes and and and and so far they
have no argument against that oh that
the I mean I haven't used the argument
of the Holocaust in my book but in
various conferences the issue arises
usually from the floor and the
the the postmodernists on the platform
say are now you're drawing extreme
examples and let's have a sensible
discussion here but the logic of the
position is still exactly the same as it
was before the questions were asked that
that interpret in the past anyway we
like goes for everybody whether they are
on the political side that you agree
with or they are not now I might just
finish my remarks with a couple of
points from the afterword the the
invasion of theory into the humanities
has been going on since the late 1970s
in history really only became a powerful
movement from the early 1980s onwards so
it's been going for almost twenty years
and so we can ask what are the actual
material results of this what are the
real consequences well if you look at
university enrollments since the 1970s
you find that they've gone through the
roof in the United States and in
Australia there's been a huge increase
in the proportion of young people
studying taking university degrees but
if you look at enrollments in history
you find that they've gone in the
opposite direction in in at the start of
the 1970s they were over 45,000
undergraduate students in the United
States taking history majors by the
start of the 1990s they were only twenty
thousand American students so that it's
more than half in terms of the number in
Australia the results have been the same
history is being abandoned by young
people in droves now there are some of
other humanities which have been
affected to a similar extent and and and
I don't want to blame cultural studies
and post-modernism for the whole of this
situation but let me quote one of
America's greatest Dorian's vane Wood
Wood who he died last year but before he
did that he participated in a symposium
where he expressed his own concern about
the developments in in his own
discipline which
I mean van wood was 98 or 99 years of
age when he died and had been the
leading figure in American
historiography for almost all he's had
at life and and he started the figures
to an historical conference that that
I'd just given you now and he said I am
of course aware that the radicals in
cultural studies and their postmodern
precursors are by no means the only
causes for the decline that history and
some of the other humanities have
suffered in the Academy in the last few
years but it's my conviction that unless
we of the Academy here and abroad must
have the courage and find effective
means to counter these forces we face a
shabby end to the discipline we are
served into any system of education that
we can respect and I think with those
sobering thoughts I will end my talk and
ask if there any questions or comments
that people would like to make yes Roger
yes you would respond to the to the
position represented by someone like say
Stanley fish who argues for example that
there is no such thing as intrinsic
truth and probably declares that he
himself is a sophist who believes that
might makes right and so on I think at
that position is is is open to the same
kind of logical objection that you
pointed out that of course we could ask
is is the statement there's no such
thing as literal truth itself a literal
truth and so on and yet
Stanley fish does have an interesting
wrinkle most people who espouse this
kind of postmodern skepticism about
truth don't really indulge in namely he
is he's quite willing to say that it
really is all a matter of politics you
know if if your side is able to muster
the votes so to speak to deny the
Holocaust then your side wins and it's
just too bad for the for the so-called
historical truths
it's it's a I think it's a cognate
position to some of the positions at you
that you Abele dissect in your book but
it seems to me to be a slightly
different position how I wonder how you
would how you would you would respond to
someone who should have granted your
logical point but then said that it
didn't really matter well truth takes no
account of democracy that truth doesn't
count heads even if there was nobody to
vote for a particular proposition if it
was true it would remain true look one
of the easiest things to do is to show
that there are capitalist facts we know
from history that are true in an
objective sense in an absolute sense and
let me take one of them one of the most
commonly known the Japanese surrendered
to the Americans in 1945 now every every
to every concept in that in that
statement is a construct of language and
culture the idea the Japanese as a group
of people as a society is a is a
cultural term the Americans as a
cultural term the idea of surrender
military surrender is
cultural linguistic term and the dates
obviously an artificial construct as
well and yet the proposition is true and
it's it's true in any culture it's just
as true in Japanese culture it is as it
is in American culture it's not a matter
of interpreting documents nobody's going
to go back and look at the documents of
surrender that was signed aboard the USS
Missouri in Tokyo Harbor in 1945 and
find I didn't surrender after all I mean
there are there are variations on
whether in economic terms the Japanese
were better off having lost the war or
and and in some sense people argue that
all the Japanese really economically won
the Second World War but they
surrendered militarily it's an objective
fact and and I mean one of the things
that postmodernists believed is that
history is merely a matter of
interpreting documents that it's a
textual activity but the the end of the
Second World War is got very little to
do with texts and interpretations it's
an event that changed the world it
affects the way we all live now affects
the kind of motor vehicles that that
drive up and down the streets and valois
it affects the whole nature of of
Japanese economy the relations between
the United States and in Asia and and
it's affected the lives of hundreds of
millions of people ever since it's not
something that that is simply a matter
that it's determined by historians
historians report it but but they
haven't been a party to creating the the
event now so getting back to your
question about about those who have the
numbers have the truth as I said before
even if there were no numbers even if
suddenly everyone drank some water that
leached their brain cells and there's a
collective loss of memory of the whole
human species irrelevant the Japanese
still lost the Second World War they
still surrendered in Tokyo Harbor in
1945 it doesn't matter if nobody ever
votes for that choice again the truth
remains
would you not agree that the ultimate
absurdity of the post structuralist
position is brought vividly
embarrassingly into focus by the efforts
to apply the same doctrines to the
physical sciences and indeed even
mathematics isn't that the ultimate
absurdity that leads from from history
to other what we used to think of as
truth or facts as that as we understood
them before well of course I mean the
only thing that well is there's a body
of theory that these days that argues
that science is simply a construction
and that it has no more veracity no more
connection with reality than then then
history in in their sense but of course
one thing that science has on its side
is is successful construction of the
physical world the fact that our
computers work that there are planes fly
through the sky other bridges stand up
all that kind of thing so testifiers on
a daily basis that even though science
may be an invention of human beings it's
it's got a fix in reality that actually
works there's an interesting debate on
the moment about the play that's
currently on Broadway called Copenhagen
which I haven't seen
but it's about partly about high
Sternberg's uncertainty principle it's
also about it's also about the the
making of the German attempts to
construct the nuclear bomb Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle has been
responsible for more mischief the name
of the uncertainty principle been
responsible for more mischief than any
other scientific principle this century
in my view see there I caused it calling
it the uncertainty principle from some
of the reviews I've read of the play and
and I maybe misquoting it so if I do
then apologies to the author but
certainly some of the reviewers got
they've got the idea that what
Heisenberg said was that at the
subatomic level everything is uncertain
there are no there are no points on
which we can stand the simple argument
against that is
that is Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle itself certain or uncertain
now Heisenberg's uncertainty principle
actually says you cannot measure the
speed and momentum of a particle at the
same time it doesn't say that the
subatomic world is is fraught with
uncertainty but I'm told I'm not a
physicist but I'm told by my physicist
friends that that all the 20th century
theories about quantum mechanics that
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle is
one that my certain of them all it's
been confirmed by empirical studies time
and time again and it's reached the
stage through corroboration and
verification that it is a preset piece
of certain knowledge and to use it as an
argument for uncertainty is is an
absurdity and a self-contradiction but I
mean put CP snows argument that there
are two cultures we have people in the
humanities who don't understand anything
about the sciences is certainly is
certainly still alive and well and you
have I you have discussions of people
have come out of seeing that play who
are quite convinced that that Heisenberg
believed that the world we inhabit is
really a massive uncertainties
yes the Australian academic and
intellectual atmosphere and that of
United States on these issues
well Australia when I was an
undergraduate in the 1960s used to be a
sort of Anglo file country we took all
our books and all our all our employed
academics were from England but in since
the 1970s and certainly in the 80s and
90s partly to do with the availability
of American books in our country we have
gone the other way in Australia now is
the sort of intellectual satellite of
the United States the theories that I'm
talking about all became fashionable in
France in the in the 60s and 70s the
United States really put them on the map
and made several of their authors like
Jacques Derrida and mikela Foucault who
spent some time in fact Derrida still in
the United States earning very high
salaries it made some of those Frenchmen
very rich Australia has has pursued the
the French theorists through its
American interpreters and even though
you can buy fucose books in Australia
most undergraduates who who talked about
Foucault are talking about so Americans
crib on Foucault rather than the
original not mind shoes not that there's
any greater virtue in in reading the
original that the cribs in my view are
just as good look one of the things I
try to do in this book just not to
answer your question but as an aside is
to sort of summarize in potted form all
these various theories to show their
connections to put them into plain and
intelligible English partly because I
spent several years of my earlier life
not as an advocate of all of them but it
certainly is never could of Wunderland
which is Foucault and I wasted in my few
many years reading all this stuff and I
think to think of people becoming sort
of as well as informal as you need to be
to
converse easily in the in the subject
matter you do need to spend several
years of your life rooting it and and to
come to the conclusion which I came to
that the whole thing was vacuous is
something you wouldn't wish on anybody
else and so what I've tried to do in the
book is to give a summary of the
arguments to show where they go wrong
and that's all done in nice potted
version in Chapter one so that hopefully
those undergraduates who want to you
know talk about Foucault or Derrida as
if they know all about it can do so
without having to wade through the real
thing and that's a normally that's a
terrible way to behave because you
really want your students to read the
primary documents but in the but in this
case the primary documents are not worth
the effort
ready other question
okay well what what mr. Olsen was asking
if you could describe you said that that
Australia is an intellectual satellite
using the word of course intellectual
the broadest possible sense of the
United States these days I wonder if if
you do you discern any greater sense of
resistance to these trends in Australia
than here I mean with the exception of
the people in this room and maybe half a
dozen others I think that that
intellectual life at least in the
Academy in this country has been supine
in mounting any kind of resistance to
this to this intellectual virus do you
see any greater resistance in
intellectual circles in Australia well
I'm more optimistic about American
intellectual life than then perhaps you
are partly because as a result of this
book I've been asked to certainly get a
lot of American academic conferences I
went one last year and got another one
next week where I've been given a
platform to to speak which has never
happened in Australia I am in in history
circles in Australia I am persona non
grata I don't get invited to be a
keynote speaker anywhere in the United
States I do which is very unusual for an
australian because usually it's very
hard for any Australian academic to
become a keynote speaker at an American
academic conference in terms of
publications most of the resistance to
post-modernism again has come from
America there I mean the the the the
greatest Park of that has been in
literary studies I think in the words of
work of John Ellison and and co-own
post-modernism not only goes into
history and English literature but it
also has had a major effect on the law
but there's a very good book published
by two American lawyers which
gives against it I was amazed to find a
fuse ago that Foucault is even now part
of the academic curriculum in
accountancy I kid you not I kid you not
it in fact I I in in in the college was
employed in the early nineties we had a
woman service or some other some other
accountancy for anyway
anyway I discovered that there was a
woman who was doing bookkeeping and this
college and she was and she saw all my
books on Foucault and she said are you a
Foucault phone line since I am I I said
oh no I can't eat for taste amongst
accountants and she taught me she was
doing a PhD on on Foucault accountancy
and not only did she do a PhD do her PhD
but she immediately was appointed as a
lecturer in pH in accountancy at the
University of New South Wales where her
supervisor the professor is one of the
most enthusiastic advocates of Foucault
in the whole university not not just in
the business field so don't ask me to
explain the Foucault account the
Foucault approach to accountancy but it
certainly they are in fact I've listed
some of the I haven't read them but I've
listed the the references in the book to
to postmodern accounting
I'm sure I'm sure it's a it's a lot of
scope free to be a growth area but
really that I mean the Americans who who
sort of made this kind of approach
really popular and put I mean in England
they were Cultural Studies theorists and
post modernists who found they were on
the sort of margins of academic life for
many years it was only when the whole
field took off in United States that the
English people in the field then became
respectable and then the Australian
acolytes followed and but fortunately
the Americans have redeemed themselves
to a certain extent because they've
become
the principle resistance to to it and
although there is a book similar to mine
which is one for promising which is
coming out of England in recent years
but I'm the only person who's written in
Australian book of this kind and I must
say that the in terms of well the
Australian sales have been okay but in
terms of population the books been far
more rarely accepted the United States
that it has been in my own country
certainly in this country it's dominated
by a wretched man named Hayden white and
are there other figures who are doing
things like you I don't think I know of
any who are doing things like me well
the most happening
thing in America is the emergence of the
Historical Society which is a new
organization of academic historians now
the American Historical Association the
specialist journal American historical
review was largely taken over by the
postmodernist so unless you wrote
articles replete with terms like
discourse and and difference and another
sort of acceptable terminology you just
you just didn't get published that's
true in Australia in our principle
historical account each journal as well
now there's there's been a resistance to
this in the United States and it's
manifested itself in an organization
called the Historical Society and the
Historical Society is interesting
because it's a combination of people who
don't easily fit together politically
even though the post modernist movement
is generally a movement on the political
left it's also had a rejection from a
number of old leftists and the
Historical Society itself says in its
its literature from Marxist left to
neoconservative we include everybody who
simply wants to get on with the business
of writing history and now that now the
United States is the only place where
there's been that kind of
you know physical on the ground
resistance to to the movement solving
talking about and so I mean who these
people are is I mean there's twelve
hundred members of the Historical
Society which is by no means large
compared to the other two major
historical societies but it's certainly
a very promising start so been going for
eighteen months the increased plane very
loose with historical truth in American
movies I don't know if you've noticed
but I mean it's virtually irrelevant
what actually happened the distortions
are so willful and I think some
commentators have pointed this out some
reviewers point this out but in general
the attitude seems to be oh well it's
just a movie is this in your view a
consequence of this essentially
intellectually sloppy way of approaching
history in general or is it as it's
something else well it's it goes back
long before the movements that I'm
talking about or even even thought of
even conceived so it's obviously got
longer legs than that
I mean Hollywood operates on dramatic
conventions and and one of the the
original points of which
facilities-based his approach to early
history was that he would issue romantic
conventions I mean Aristotle said that
when you if you write a speech for a
drama you write it not as it was
actually stated but as it ought to have
been stated in fact in the history the
Peloponnesian War the events that
Thucydides describes he says I described
them exactly as they happen but the
speeches he in fact invented and the
most famous speech of all Pericles
funeral oration which was the the basis
of Lincoln's famous Gettysburg Address
was in fact written by facilities rather
than by
Pericles in the way that he thought
Pericles should have done it now people
who came out at this Synod he said well
that's really that's really break this
is acidities is breaking his own rules
by adopting that dramatic convention
history should tell it like it is rather
than tell it the way it would be more
dramatic to tell it now
Hollywood is a dramatic medium and it
goes by dramatic conventions although I
must say one of the the best pieces of
filmmaking this piece of American
filmmaking I've ever seen
is the faithful reproduction of
Gettysburg a film called Gettysburg
which is very long because the but it
recreates the battle scenes filmed on
the battle and on the battlefield and is
that it attempts to be apart from
cutting and editing and shortening the
whole thing attempts to be to tell it
like it is in the way that if you're
writing about it you would tell it like
it is and it seems to me that Hollywood
may well underestimate the market for
veracity the truthfulness but you know
the the the inventions that I would I
mean it's often all you're getting from
there from a historical movie is the
name is the same as the event in the
past and everything else has been
changed it
students forgetting now the academic
leadership is there anything happening
well again one of the heartening things
and this is again a United States
phenomenon is amongst graduate students
I get a lot of fan email in fact I've
had one of the best reviews I had was on
the internet from a graduate student at
Berkeley and and what a lot of graduate
students tell me I mean it's the old
story if you have an orthodoxy it breeds
a heresy and the young most susceptible
to that to the heretics are excited by
by rejecting the views of their teachers
and I'm in a sort of fortunate position
of being amongst in a small group
obviously but amongst some graduate
students a kind of heretical figure
which they approve and who they can use
to fly their superiors but the problem
for them though is that with declining
enrollments in history there are
declining academic jobs and if you an
academia is a system of patronage and if
you don't tow the line of your superiors
you you sort of decrease your chances of
getting employment and so in a shrinking
market to be a heretic is almost a sort
of guarantee of unemployment so I'm sort
of I have a survey and big Lluis
relationship to some of these graduate
students I like the prize but I feel
they will never practice as historians
in the university scene because nobody's
going to give them a job
I'm happy to say that counter Books has
made available some copies of the
killing of history which you can
purchase for a very reasonable price and
I'm sure that Keith winshuttle will be
delighted to inscribe it with best
wishes